un véritable basculement dans la vie
politique française
emmanuel macron devient le 7 mai 2010
est président de la république
vainqueur avec son mouvement en marche
et avec la volonté de bousculer le
clivage classique entre la droite et la
gauche
malgré une abstention record pour une
présidentielle il est élu avec 66% des
suffrages face à marine le pen une
victoire retentissante jusqu'à
versailles avec les marcheurs illinois
emmanuel bach c'est justement de
permettre un pur et français der croire
en nous et de re croire dans cette belle
dame qu'est la cinquième but est d'aller
à la soupe
l'évolution démocratique
versailles théâtre diplomatique aussi en
2010 est le président le plus jeune de
la vème république a choisi le château
pour recevoir le président russe
vladimir poutine et tenter de relancer
les relations franco russes sur de
nouvelles bases
après la présidentielle les élections
législatives dans les yvelines les
républicains et le parti socialiste ne
résiste pas à la déferlante bastion de
la droite depuis 1993 les yvelines
bascule en faveur des marcheurs ces
néophytes de la politique rafle 11
sièges sur 12 je pense que c'est aussi
la confirmation que le projet que nous
portons le projet que nous avons
construit avec les français est un
projet qui finalement rassure les
français et veulent qu'ils veulent le
voir au moins essayé pour les cinq ans
qui viennent nous on est clairement dans
une période là il faut refonder refonder
la gauche c'est d'ailleurs ce que benoît
hamon a commencé à dire et qui va faire
dès le 1er juillet le milieu d'année est
aussi marquée par des révolutions
sportive à plaisir en valeur et rugbyman
entre dans une nouvelle dimension les
hommes de victor garrigues et obtiennent
enfin leur ticket en nationale 3 après
avoir lutté six ans en prénationale je
pense que ça représente énormément pour
le public pour le club les anciens du
club le tout les dirigeants les
bénévoles les petits enfin c'est
vraiment assez rarement une grande
famille c'est pour tout le monde voilà
c'est pas que nous c'est pas que les
doux c'est vraiment un un club qui avec
lui ce moment là tout son sens l'air de
son côté le 15 plaisir waro monte en
fédérale 2 3 ans après avoir quitté
cette division le travail effectué toute
la saison pour nous avec frédéric jardin
des moyens un équipe première mais c'est
le résultat d'un travail sur deux années
du combat il y en a eu à voisins le
bretonneux la commune a failli basculer
du côté obscur de la force rebelle et
jedi se sont opposées le temps d'un
week-end au gymnase des pyramides une
convention star wars organisé par
l'académie des sabres laser vie sinoise
prestation le côté obscur illuminé par
les clubbers et les dj au vélodrome
national de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
pendant une nuit la piste de cyclisme
sur piste s'est transformée en piste de
danse house electro techno avec des
relais aux platines entre plusieurs
artistes
s'asseoir entre les gens de voir dans
les clubs déjà et puis je trouve que
ça va dans la logique de la
démocratisation de de la techno est
d'alluré retrouvant enfin innovation sur
les greens du golf national de
guyancourt l'open de france est entré en
2017 dans une nouvelle ère à un an de la
ryder cup le groupe chinois à chen a
permet au tournoi de devenir l'une des
compétitions les plus attractives en
europe avec une notation de plus de 7
millions de dollars
un pactole est remporté par le
britannique tommy fleetwood